this is one of the most common mistakes
i see of visionary uh uh founding
leaders founder leaders where to your
point they have cult of personality and
you know whether it's sam walton or
steve jobs like we know who these people
are richard branson we know who these
people are elon musk right
mark benioff we know who these people
are
and one of the biggest mistakes they all
make
is they think that everyone in the
company is as clear on their vision as
they are
uh because it's clear to them they just
assume it's clear to everyone and they
don't think they need to go through the
process
of of putting that just cause and terms
that have nothing to do with the company
or themselves and uh the the work that
they uh fail to do in acculturating the
vision outside of them because they're
they have such outsized influence over
the course of the
course of the organization and we talked
about courage before they're the ones
who say no to the pressures of wall
street for example um
unfortunately so many of them
uh replace themselves with operators a
visionary replaces themselves with an
operator now inherently that's not
necessarily a bad thing operators can
absolutely do a visionary job but they
have to know that it's a different job
and the skill set that they've developed
over a 20 or 30 year career
being a cfo or co getting really good at
it actually has to change
and so so many of these folks replace
themselves with their cfo or their co
and when asked why did you choose that
person they all say the same thing
i trust them more than anybody true they
know more about the workings of this
company than i do
true i couldn't do it without them true
except for the fact that it's a
different skill set
one is up and out the other one is down
and in and again yes a cfo or co could
take over that ceo role but have to
understand that up and out is now their
job that being in the weeds and in the
details and worrying about the short
term is no longer their job
uh um and i think we actually do
ourselves a disservice in business
by thinking of cfos or cos as number two
in the company
you know that many of them think they're
in line for the big job
um and it's one in a it's a partnership
it's visionary and operator who it's the
push me pull you it's the tension of
those two skill sets and those two ways
of operating up and out and down and in
that uh you know very very long term to
shorter term that make an organization
highly highly highly functional um and
so
so one of the things we have to do is
you want a visionary person and a
visionary job
you want an operator and an operator job
you want to do the the hard work of
extracting that why that purpose from
that founder leader in terms that are
compelling uh and resonant with everyone
else and you want to make sure that your
values are built in and built into your
incentive structure not just performance
but your values as well so that the
organization is equipped to survive that
founder leader for
a century if necessary or more